all right guys
bang bang i have a very special treat
today
uh miss patty sellers is here thank you
so much for doing this patty
thanks anthony um for the like
one or two people who are watching this
who have no clue who you are
uh let's start off with kind of just a
quick summary of your background and
then what you are
are doing today sure sure uh i joined
fortune
a couple of years out of college uh over
30 years ago
and uh was a writer for many years and
rose through the ranks to
senior writers specializing in profiling
masters of the universe i mean i did a
lot of fortune 500 companies but i wrote
about
you know like world changers and
entrepreneurs and a lot of the tech
entrepreneurs and um and i rose to you
know
fort assistant managing editor at
fortune which is one of the top
positions and in the process built
something called
fortune most powerful women with an
increasingly
big and fantastic team and then almost
five years ago went off and started my
own
company with a woman named nina easton
from fortune it's called sellers easton
media
and that's my story in a minute very
efficient
uh let's start off with uh the seller's
easton media today because i think what
you guys are doing
is a very kind of unique um uh
twist on storytelling so just give us
kind of an overview what do you guys
actually do today and then we'll go
backwards and
kind of how you got there but what
exactly is easton media
so sellers eastern media is a very sort
of high-end
content creation company that we say we
tell stories of leadership and impact
and we work with the kind of people
and companies that i spent my whole
career writing about at fortune
and think about like what you do as a
as a journalist you write stories
you appear on stage you interview people
you interview people on video it
quickly became a multimedia job
we decided five years ago hey
everybody wants to be a storyteller
today
you don't need traditional media to get
your story out there
you can pick your audience and for all
the stuff that people are putting on
social media
the quality is is fine for the purpose
but
for people who want to produce content
and put it on a platform
to reach five people or five million
people
there really wasn't anybody out there
who had the sort of
interviewing storytelling skills that
nina easton and i have
and so basically we sort of hung our
shingle
i was told recently that that's a that's
a term that
like young people don't know but i still
use it
we hung our shingle and we
started a company that basically kind of
transfers
what we were doing for the doing for the
public
at fortune and carries it to a private
market so we have clients who are
companies fortune 500 companies a lot of
small investment firms we've done work
for hedge funds and
um companies that have a sort of
high-end audience
and want to reach them in a
sophisticated way whether it's through
writing video filmed interviews podcasts
and we work for wealthy families too and
some non-profit work but
you know it's basically people who
want to put their message out there in a
sophisticated way
and you know really care about
i mean we we say and and we've lived up
to this
we tell stories of leadership and impact
and we believe that a life well-lived
is one where you make a positive impact
on the world
so not to be too pollyannish about that
or self-important but
we do tend to have those kind of
companies as clients and people
so you are incredibly humble and won't
say this but i will
uh the roll of decks that you have built
over the years
literally encapsulates the world's most
powerful and successful people
you've uh spent an entire career writing
about them for the public as you
described
and now you tell a lot of those stories
uh in a more private setting
can you give us maybe one or two
examples in terms of uh you don't have
to name names but
uh the types of the types of products
that you guys build right so i'm
cheating because i know about
kind of the books that you put together
or the the uh
documentary style content but maybe just
give us a couple of examples
of some of the work that you guys have
done sure sure
well um i've done several projects for
john mack
the former ceo morgan stanley uh
he wanted he has three children and he
wanted to tell his you know his father
so he was ceo of morgan stanley until
2010 and he carried the fur he spent
most of his career there he carried the
firm through the
2008 financial crisis and you know he
sort of picked and the board picked
james gorman who is doing such a good
job there now
uh as his successor but he is the son of
incredibly poor lebanese immigrants who
came to this country with
his father started selling selling pots
and pans door-to-door
out of a pack on its back and john grew
up with a father who had a wholesale
grocery business
you know build it from scratch in north
carolina
and so i we do these film life story
interviews we call them so i interviewed
john
and you know like less fewer than
probably five people have seen this uh
although he allows me to talk about it
and he was and then i did his wife
christy
i did did her story filmed interview
and then i've i've worked with him on a
couple of other projects
um including a book project um
we you know i did a similar film life
story interview
for susie buffett lauren's daughter and
i've come to know warren buffett
really well over the last couple of
decades and
know the whole family and susie who has
talked a lot about her father if you
google her you'll see videos of her
talking about her father
and and she has a foundation and she's
an amazing wonderful person but
she had never told her story
and her kids who i know found out that
i'm like oh patty sellers is doing that
so they said mom you've got to do that
so i did that for her and
again like probably five people have
seen that and
um and then i've done several other
you know kind of like um you know
like billionaires i mean this is this is
a this is our most popular
project product in that it takes you
know as i said to john
i said let me come over to your house
with a small tv quality camera crew and
we'll be done by noon
and we were and he had a lunch that day
and a few weeks later we
you know we clean it up we put pictures
in we also do
i can't i can't tell you who the client
is it's a very
big name uh in silicon valley
former ceo of a fortune 500 company
who's very well known
um we do this this service called modern
family
portrait where every year we do a family
film
so we go every year to their home they
have little kids
and we capture the family over a couple
of days
you know playing eating i interview them
and we're doing this over you know like
probably more than a decade for this
particular family in silicon valley
um and then we do a lot of we do a lot
of corporate work too
and we do work for some from some
nonprofits we're doing a huge project
for
uh the university of texas right now and
so
it's it's great because it's you know
it's
truly multimedia i mean we're living in
a world where
if you can tell your story one way
and you kind of get it down on video i
mean
anthony you you know your podcast is
also a
it's filmed interviews you put these on
youtube so the more you can repurpose
this content
uh the better and you just need sort of
good interviewers like you
to start and then you can splice and
dice it
i'm uh i'm learning everything from you
don't worry
it's good so you're really good let's
back up a second
and talk about where did your
fascination come
from in terms of wanting to better
understand
uh what i'll call kind of the most
successful people in companies
uh and also wanting to tell their
stories like where did that
interest or intrigue come from i grew up
in allentown pennsylvania the daughter
of a dentist and a
housewife and an only child who was very
shy when i was growing up
but you know i my parents had me when
they were
39 years old and which back then was
old and i grew up around adults
and i was very comfortable around adults
and shy around
kids and i knew no business people like
my father's friends were
doctors mostly doctors and you know
independent
business people in allentown
pennsylvania
and i think i grew up observing
a lot and watching people
and then i went to university of
virginia
and i wanted to i just
like my parents thought i should be a
lawyer because i asked so many
questions but i just and i thought about
that but i really
loved i loved writing i loved asking
questions so i i got a job with a
startup business newspaper in
northern virginia i wanted to write
about people in the arts
i had no interest in business and um but
i kind of fell in that this was like
the only job i could get and i liked i
found i
liked business i liked writing about
people in business because
these people are smart
and they can get things done so
two years later i was two years out of
college i
applied to fortune forbes businessweek
and inc
magazine which was just starting up and
i
i worked at this washington business
journal with a woman who was on the
founding team of ink magazine
and i just thought she was so cool her
name was susan currier
oh no i don't know if she's still around
but anyway she was so cool and so nice
to me
and i just you know i thought wow
i want to work for a business magazine
and fortune hired me they were the only
ones or the first the only ones
to hire me and i started as a reporter
in 1984.
and um so but you know
it was a company that was like famous
for the fortune it was a magazine famous
for the fortune 500.
and i was like not that interested in
writing about
companies or things i wanted to write
about people
and over the decades i just kind of
found my niche and i was the person
who more than anyone there i spent years
chasing some people like wanting to get
the first
exclusive story about them
and i did i mean i i mean i'll just
throw out three names
um melinda gates oprah winfrey
and martha stewart when she when she was
in prison
so i want to play a game with you and i
think as we play this game
we'll unpack uh kind of a lot of the
techniques that you use to do this and
really become the best in the world at
it
let's start with melinda gates so my
understanding of the situation is
linda gates had done press before but
never kind of exclusively
by herself in a profile format right no
one had ever written
the melinda gates approved profile of
her
right you were able to successfully do
that how do you
meet her how do you convince her to do
it and then what was the process like
actually
writing that kind of first exclusive
profile of her
i gosh i spent a couple of years
talking to and writing letters
to um
the gates foundation and her people
and she had done quite a lot of press
with bill as they were building the
gates foundation
but she had never she had never agreed
to do an interview for
a profile about her
so i wanted to do the first major
profile
and i don't know finally i got in it was
the
i remember i went to seattle
the monday after or the tuesday i guess
it was
after labor day in 2007
and i remember the the new head of pr
for the gates foundation
was a woman named heidi sinclair she's
one of my closest friends today
i stayed friends with her and um she was
like her first week on the job and
melinda was so nervous
and i ended up interviewing melinda like
three times for that story once in new
york and
i interviewed bill in seattle separately
for that
and i interviewed you know a bunch of
that and i melinda was great though like
she
um she let me talk to her best friend
you know i went over to her best
friend's house
on the lake and you know to her house
and like had coffee and we're sitting in
the kitchen and i'm talking about
melinda
and like melinda had never told her
story melinda had never talked about how
when she was young right out of duke and
duke university and working at microsoft
you know
kind of low level and she was walking
across the parking lot someday
and she saw the ceo the founder bill
gates and she said hello to him
and he asked her out and
and and anyway they fell in like she
she really dished and oh my god it was
fantastic they lined up bono for me and
i remember i talked to bono
and so it was great i mean they really
went all out
and then the story came out right at
christmas time
and i got the nicest email over
christmas from melinda
um telling me she was with her parents
and her parents actually loved it
loved the story and that was a cover
story and that was
you know like the ultimate like
quintessential
like brand of stamp of approval and then
my mother died three weeks later
and my mother loved loved loved that
story that was like the
her favorite story of all that i had
done and that was
i had been at fortune for 24 years at
that point so
um wait no uh 84.
yeah 2 had been a fortune for 24 years
at that point so in a quarter of a
century that was the favorite story that
she
so it holds a lot of meaning to me for
various reasons yeah and what was like
the biggest surprise to that whole
process right when she agrees
you go and you talk to everyone you talk
to bill you kind of hear all the stories
was there one thing that kind of stood
out to you that
was either a surprise or you didn't
really understand until you had done all
the work
so i forgot to i actually went i already
knew
warren buffett well at that point but i
had never been out to omaha
so i went out to omaha for that story i
mean i could have interviewed warren on
the phone but
i you know i said i think i said to him
i said this would be a good chance for
me to finally come out
and you know see you in your office so i
went out
and they had announced the giving pledge
together where warren
warren who did not expect to give
any of his money away until
he died and he thought his wife susie
would die
he thought he would he he never imagined
that he would outlive his wife susie so
here he is he lost his wife he has all
this money
doesn't know what to do with it doesn't
know how to be a philanthropist
he says it's harder than making money so
he announces
this was before this couple few years
before the story came out
he announces that he's giving all his
money to the gates's
to distribute because they're experts
so anyway that's why and obviously
as most people know bill and melinda and
warren are really close so i went out to
omaha
and here's the answer to your question
warren tells me how
ins to an extraordinary degree
melinda kind of
first of all convinced bill to give
his money away during his lifetime
and you know i can't remember the
details but convinced warren
also of the value of that because there
are all these diseases around the world
and children are dying people are dying
every day and
you know let's not save it let's put it
to good use
and warrant just i mean there's that
that sort of aha moment wow that's what
we should do with our money
but warren loves
melinda because melinda has done
for bill what susie
did for warren which is basically
take a nerdy guy who is like
all business and all numbers
and
finds the kind of humanity
in him and so it's one of the reasons
that warren and bill are so close
and it's one of the reasons that warren
and melinda are so close because he sees
a lot of susie and melinda
i love that story yeah um you
and martha stewart while she's in jail
tell us that story
that is absolutely epic
oh geez i had met martha in 1998
when i did a story called it was a cover
story for fortune called women's sex and
power
and it was an idea that i had to do a
story about i literally walked into the
office of the top
editor of fortune at the time john huey
and said i think we should do a story
about women who are doing better than
men
and he goes what do you mean i said well
women who are like
doing amazing things that no man has
ever done or no ban
so anyway long story short
through that story i met martha
i actually had a sort of an evening with
her and
and two of her friends um
charlotte beers who was the head of
ogilvy and made her the big ad agency at
the time and a woman named darla moore
who i ended up doing a cover story about
the following year
do you know darla moore is anthony
she would be of interest to a lot of
your
a lot of your listeners because she was
the she
she was the wife of the late richard
rainwater do you know who richard
rainwater i do
yeah yeah big self-made billionaire
but anyway so i met i met
martha in 1998 one night
at the apartment of charlotte beers with
darla moore in new york um
we started two years later we fortune
started fortune most powerful women
which was which started as a list of the
50 most powerful women in business we
put
martha on the list for several years she
was building her
empire then she
lied about a stock trade and she
got convicted i went to the trial
i was in touch with her during the trial
i knew her i had written about her
um she got convicted she got
sent down to a prison in west virginia
for five months and then
served five months house arrest and
during the time that she was in prison
and by the way i mean i think that
it was sort of a travesty i mean she
lied to investigators
and she paid really really big
and i'm just gonna fast forward to for a
second like the way
she handled that gives us all
provides lessons for us all in dealing
with adversity because she handled it in
the
most amazing and and quite frankly
classy way
but anyway when she was in prison i
i wanted to do the first story about her
after she got out of prison
and i i ended up sending her
magazines every week
through her assistant who sent a bag i
think every friday down to west virginia
and so i would send over to julia at
martha stewart living on the media
a packet of the magazines at time inc
we used to get them they'd all be
displayed we could all grab them
people time sports illustrated
and put together a packet every week and
send them down
and martha really appreciated it you
know this was before
i mean this was like 2004
i mean the internet people were reading
on the internet but not as much
people were really still like reading
physical magazines
so anyway she got out of prison uh they
wouldn't let me see her
uh there was a whole army of pr people
around her
no no no no no she's not doing
interviews
and she called me one day and she said
come on monday morning i think she
called me like on a saturday and she
called me she said i'll i'll talk to you
let's talk about this story you want to
do
come monday morning and i got a um
dial car one of those like 777 cars this
was long before uber
got a car went up to bedford new york
where she lived
and i remember right as we were pulling
up i got a call from her pr person like
her head head pr
person oh my god what are you doing
martha just told me she called you and
invited you oh my god
so martha did this like totally behind
the back of her
advisors and it was great she was
wearing her
ankle ankle bracelet and we talked and
she said let's go down to the stables
she said i only have like
20 minutes before i before i violate my
leaving this house or whatever and we
jumped in the car and we
went down to her stables and she showed
me around and i ended up i ended up
getting the exclusive like you know she
we did a cover story where the cover
line was
it was a quote from her and the cover
line was
i cannot be destroyed
that was the line great picture of her
and that
line and really big print oh my gosh
she just hated the cover line she loved
the cover picture but she hated the
cover
line it was true and she
you know she could not be destroyed and
uh so anyway i mean i i really like
martha and i see her
you know every once in a while i mean
not like one-on-one i see her at events
she
continued to come to our most powerful
women events when we were doing them
live
now we're doing them virtually but you
know i just admire her
one of the things that always helped me
as a journalist
was i found i liked more
people than other journalists liked
why do you think that is i think i'm
i think i'm more open and trusting
and accepting and optimistic
than most journalists are and that's
both a blessing and a curse
because early in my career
i i really all i'm
and i'm still i'm no longer a journalist
so i
it's a little bit less of a concern for
me
but i was always afraid about kind of
being taken
and being gullible anthony you don't
know me
quite well enough but if you want to
pull a practical joke on me
pretty easy that's fine listen you gotta
have fun in life
every once in a while you get got but uh
you did a pretty good job of
avoiding that professionally uh ted
turner
is a fascinating character i've read the
book uh i think that he wrote his
autobiography um
and he's waiting yeah he's one of these
guys who
uh obviously most people know him as uh
you know for cnn and kind of the media
side but
everything from the american bisons all
the way down just a really fascinating
guy
tell us the biggest fight owner in the
world yeah but
how did you meet him and kind of what
were the the interesting parts there
how did i meet ted um
i think my fur the first time i met
ted was when i
did a story about
i did a cover story in the
like maybe around 2000 or so like 20
years ago
about how
big time business people like sort of
even bigger than fortune 500 ceos sort
of masters of the universe
kind of relax
detox relax get away from it all
and john huey
who was the top editor of fortune at the
time knew ted they were both from
atlanta
and he called ted and he said would you
let patty sellers you know come to
montana
so i think that was my first time
meeting ted i went to montana
and he was married to jane fonda at the
time and i remember
we had lunch at uh
and jane was serving these bison burgers
and it was just so bizarre
it was just and then we went out and i'm
in this like
you know vehicle with ted i mean his
his ranch is like practically the size
of rhode island
i mean you know this is a ranch anyway
i mean i basically did it was like you
know kind of puff journalism but we took
we had a like a top top a fantastic
photographer with us and we ended up
taking that day i remember
jane fonda's favorite picture of ted
like of all time and then i did a story
so he ended up so time
warner so warner brothers bought time
uh warner warner brothers taught time
warner brothers ended up owning time
and turner okay turner which is cnn tnt
uh tbs you know the whole media empire
ted turner was to television
what um you know name a
name a tech entrepreneur is to you know
so
so time warner ends up owning us
and turner enterprises time warner
does a merger
with it's like 20 years ago with aol
okay worst merger in history
the stock went from like 100 to 10.
ted was such a loyal soldier
he had he never diversified his
portfolio
he never bought i don't think in his
whole career
he's you know ted is like in his late
70s now or maybe he just turned 80.
um but i don't think in his whole career
he ever owned a stock outside of
time warner okay so he loses eight
billion dollars
ted lost eight billion dollars on one
stock
he was the second biggest lando owner in
the united states
so he still had assets
still had money so i did a story then
ted knew me he trusted me and i did a
cover story that we ended up calling
gone with the wind and the cover line
was
gone with the wind ted turner
sounds off on losing
eight billion dollars his job
and the love of his life who was jane
and he lost he got he got pushed out as
vice chairman of
of time warner and so anyway i
ended up spending a lot of time with ted
at one ranch
and on his um he has a huge it was
called a plantation at the time it
probably is not called that
anymore for kind of
obvious reasons yeah but he had a
plantation in northern florida
and um i went down there and spent time
with them
and uh the house looks like
tara from gun with the wind um
you know he's he's obsessed with he had
bought he had bought mgm
so he could have gone with the wind but
anyway
uh he was just oh my god he i mean he
talked about
how he had been suicidal and
um it was just i mean it was great i
mean he's a really one of the hardest
interviews that i've ever done and i've
interviewed him many many times
but he you know he's
he's not a normal kind of guy
but sometimes the world's greatest
entrepreneurs are people who
are certainly not normal
and um at the time he was just
so he was so obsessed with rupert
murdoch
and he kept saying to me like probably
10 times in the course of my
interview interviewing him rupert
murdoch is the most dangerous man in the
universe
i mean ted is very liberal and you know
fox news was beating
cnn in the ratings and
it was just killing ted so this is
interesting because
uh one you knew ted pretty well
getting somebody to do a cover story
about losing eight billion dollars the
love of their life and their job is
probably no
easy task and i can only imagine the
complexities with interviewing them
during a time like that
but you also knew rupert murdoch and had
written about him as well and so maybe
tell us that story and then
compare like how do you uh kind of
balance right you you know multiple
people in these stories and
and know that people don't like each
other yeah and so just like
you know how did you meet rupert murdoch
and then you know was rupert murdoch
when you're talking to him
you know yelling and screaming about ted
turner or does he not even really care
how does that work no rupert you know
rupert
is it's so interesting i mean ted
ted obviously like thinks big and but
ted
gets you know kind of gets obsessed with
things
rupert is rupert is more
rupert is just completely different from
ted so i had not met rupert at the time
um i i can't remember what kind of
incentivized me or got me
wanting to do a big rupert murdoch
interview but
i got to the point in my career and this
is maybe 10 years ago
where i had been at fortune for you know
25 years i had
chased a lot of people i had done two
cover stories about oprah who had never
done a business story she was another
one that was like on my list i was
frankly running out of people who i was
dying to write about
and so i don't know rupert murdoch was
fascinating to me
and i ended up doing in 2000 and
i don't know 14 maybe 13.
the first sit-down interview public sit
down
interview he's done some private stuff
for sort of like private conferences and
stuff but
public sit down interview with with
rupert
and i think it had been like six years
or something
and i'm not sure that he's done another
one in the last
several years um it's kind of
anyway i did it with him in his office
in new york
and he was fantastic and he
talked about you know he talked about
everything he talked about his children
his difficulty with his you know his
children the sort of rocky relationships
over the years
um his um
you know his marriage he talked about
i was kind of stunned but you know
one of the things that i like about
interviewing people at this level who
are not
fortune 500 ceos now he is a fortune 500
ceo he's a fortune global 500 ceo but
he controls you know nobody's telling
him what to do
he start he's an entrepreneur i
love interviewing these people
because
they just they don't
they're they're just they talk more
freely they talk more freely and they're
more courageous
in their views and i just never wanted
to be strapped down by doing like just i
did plenty of like
you know i grew up writing about coke
and pepsi and
and craft and kellogg and all those
companies and they were fine but like
i always wanted to to capture people
really authentically and i felt i could
do that with these people who
kind of played by their own rules
yeah the last person i want to talk
about before i kind of ask you some
questions just in general
is uh alex rodriguez who i know you're
close with
you wrote a a very big article on him in
fortune magazine
at a time in his life where i think he
was kind of going through
multiple transitions so he'd been banned
by baseball
he was also kind of sitting out for the
year because of the baseball the
situation
uh he had gone from you know hero in the
media and the sports world to kind of
you know shunned a little bit uh and
then he was also focusing on me
a little more than a little uh being
kind uh
but but also had kind of aspirations
from a very young age really to kind of
be successful in the business and
investing world and it seems like had
really kind of hit the gas pedal
on you know he had a capital base but he
wanted to learn he wanted to to go and
do this
so maybe talk a little bit about uh you
know one just
your relationship with alex how you met
him but also two writing about
somebody in a time where um it was a
complicated story right it's not kind of
one single story to tell how did you
kind of navigate that
i met alex in the lobby of
the hilton omaha the omaha hilton hotel
in 2014 which was
the year he was banned from baseball and
he was very
quiet that year and he was using that
year
to um kind of
get his head together and
learn he took college classes he went to
conferences
he went to the milken conference in la
he went to the berkshire hathaway annual
meeting
he went to some other business
conferences and
i had the it's the weirdest weirdest
story
um and yes i'm we're actually now doing
work
for for for his company a-rod corp at
sellers easton but
just going back to that moment which is
just
it was kind of an amazing moment because
i had just flown in from los angeles
where i had done something on stage at
the milken conference
and i had heard that morning
that alex rodriguez was in the audience
during the session that i did and how
alex was telling people that it was his
favorite session
at the milken conference and i'm like
what that's kind of cool
and and alex at the time this was
pre-jennifer lopez
and he was the guy he was the
the legendary baseball player who was
banned okay and there was an aura of
mystery about him
so i'm literally so i go to omaha for
the berkshire hathaway annual meeting
this was like
may 1st 2014 and i'm standing in the
lobby
talking with two friends like at the bar
at the side of the bar
and i'm telling them i'm like yeah i
just got back from i came in from the
milken conference in la
and alex rodriguez was apparently at my
thing
as i am saying this anthony i swear i'm
not embellishing this story
as i'm saying this alex walks by
and i go oh my god there he is
there's alex rodriguez so i
stepped forward and i go
alex and he turns around
and we're about probably 20 feet away
from each other and
he stops turns around i approach him and
i said alex i'm patty sellers
i said i he goes i know who you are i
was at your session yesterday
i said i heard you were at the session
and i said thank you for coming and
thank you he said yeah it was fantastic
and so anyway he gives me his card we're
standing there talking
like five minutes or so he's giving this
guy so this is really your email address
and he goes of course it's my email
address i'm giving you my card
and i'm like all right and he goes i've
he said i've seen you on he said i've
followed your stuff for years
i've he he goes i've watched you on
video i've seen you interviewing marissa
meyer
on video and he pronounced meyer
correctly
which which is always a sign the former
ceo of yahoo
a lot of people say i mean i yeah a lot
of people say mayor
but it's marissa meyer so anyway i ended
up seeing him seeing him the next day
during the berkshire hathaway annual
meeting at a lunch
and we talked and he said well he said
to me in the lobby that day he said you
know i don't care if i'm
ever in sports illustrated again
my dream is to be on the cover of
fortune
and he said that's long been my dream
and he said you know i started my
company back in 2003
and he said i started building uh buying
apartments
and he has thousands and thousands and
thousands
i mean i think over 15 000 apartment
units now as well as
a huge um venture business he's invested
in
over 50 companies and he's done
very very well and he has a team of
a big team and it's called a-rod corp
and um
so anyway long story short i ended up
doing the first
interview that he agreed to do
after he was banned he had not talked to
the press
so he gave he said he said i'll give you
the exclusive
i didn't know if i could trust him he
came through
and um he did a good we did a great
interview here in
here in new york he was living on the
upper west side of manhattan at the time
and we did an
interview at his uh at his apartment
building
and then um and then yeah i started we
started the company
and so we're doing we're actually doing
some work for him now and he's a great
guy he's really a great guy and i just
i met jennifer recently and she's
wonderful and so um
anyway you know it's it's just
interesting getting behind the
the curtain of these people who are i
think i'm
drawn as a as a sort of recovering
journalist
i'm drawn to people who are not
understood
you know they may be controversial and
um i
i just you know i i think there are
people
some people who like i think there are
you know a lot of good people who make
bad decisions and it changes their life
yeah there's two themes um in the times
that we've talked that i think i've been
able to pull out
um and and you mentioned one of them at
dinner the other night which is
uh all of these people work really
really hard
and i think that one of the public uh
you know kind of expectations is oh that
person got lucky
it doesn't matter if you're an athlete
if you're a business person like nobody
wants to believe that kind of the secret
ingredient to
a lot of success and ultimately creating
a powerful person
is hard work so maybe talk a little bit
about just
you've literally seen behind the
curtains spent hours and hours if not
days with many of the world's most
powerful people
talk a little bit about the work ethic
and kind of how that might surprise
people to see really what these people
do on a day-to-day basis
well okay i mean just taking alex he
works
all the time i mean all the time all the
time
and it's it's impressive and i mean you
know
some of these like former athletes have
you know investment firms or companies
where
there isn't a lot behind the curtain
and i mean boy alex
is he is he is
as hard as he worked to become
the you know the number four home run
king in mlb history
he is working just as hard to he wants
to be warren buffett
and warren is his role model and their
friends
and he the thing that i
that surprised me about alex when i
first met him
is he is insatiable
in wanting to learn and wanting to
improve himself
and you know as i said that year that he
was banned from baseball he spent
it literally going to school and going
to these conferences
and he just wants to learn and he has a
a little bit of a dreamy attitude about
college which he didn't go to he
actually got a football scholarship to
the university of miami and he passed it
up to go with the tech with the uh
you know to to be a professional
baseball player but
anyway um so he works super hard martha
stewart never stops
um oprah never stops
um i one of the things that
that helped me a lot in
being a journalist who could write about
these sort of billionaires and world
changers
and helps me as a
co-ceo now doing private work for them
is
i have never ever like won iota
wanted to be them um
i have never been jealous of any i've
been in
countless billionaires homes
i've never been jealous for a second
i've never wanted that
to me money
brings i know you have an audience
anthony
who you know people who care about money
want to make a lot of money for better
or worse
i never have cared about that i love
doing the work
i love the process and i have a co-ceo
now nina easton
who who kind of chides me like you know
this is about making money and she's she
cares about the work equally but
um so
you know a lot of these people who you
know whether you're talking about
ted turner or martha stewart or alex
rodriguez or oprah winfrey or
um you know tech entrepreneurs you know
i mean i met steve jobs
i um
of course they want to make money but
none
of these people none of these people are
in it
to make money primarily
these are all people who want to
either make their mark
change the world for good
um or
or or prove themselves
out of some insecurity yeah
i think that that is a uh a thing that
when you unpack most people
you just nailed it uh but in order to be
able to unpack that
you've gotta build trust and you've
mentioned a couple of times here
um trust in the sense of either you've
got to be able to actually trust the
people that you're
to do a story on or they need to be able
to trust you to
kind of not screw them over or have any
sort of gotcha type
situation talk a little bit just about
how do you
one build the trust with them and then
also to learn to trust them
so that you kind of understand that this
is a two-way street
and you know we're gonna kind of go on
this journey together really
uh to create a profile that ends up
being uh one accurate but also too
entertaining and valuable for readers
yeah well
it's it's so hard
to it it used to be so hard i mean i'm
talking about like
before the internet um back in the 80s
when i started writing for fortune
um people would tell me like
people who i remember i was at pepsico
and i was interviewing the ceo of
pepsico and
like the head of pr said said
you know you do interviews like sort of
like
it's like a living room conversation
you know it's so intimate and so i'm
like well
how do most people do interviews you
know
i think first of all listening as you
know
anthony and from watching your show
in the past i i you know i've thought
countless times he's a really good
listener
you are you're a really good listener
and that is like that's job one for us
right
um i think a lot of journalists have a
list of questions
and they're like that does not
build trust what builds trust is
listening being able to step into the
other person's shoes
understanding what makes them
comfortable
and what doesn't and what will
sort of help sort of um
you know just open them up um
i mean i never i never did gotcha
journalism
um it's interesting we're working right
now with i'm really sort of jumping
right now but we're working right now
we've gotten into the documentary
business at sellers easton and i've
never actually
said this or but it just popped into my
head
we are we're we're doing a
we're working on a major civil rights
documentary that we've raised a couple
million dollars for
and we're we're working with a director
named barbara koppel
who is legendary in the world of
documentary filmmaking
and she um has won two academy awards
for best documentary
and her style is cinema verite which is
basically following people around and
being a fly on the wall with a camera
she does straight interviews but mostly
it's you know kind of like
lurking and capturing what's happening
in the moment
among all documentary filmmakers she is
way way up there in terms of like people
trust barbara koppel
because she is not a gotcha journalist
she wants to she wants to
um you know she she works super super
hard to get people to trust her
and i just think like i think
i i wanted
i've always wanted to do the same thing
i've wanted to
capture what people are
all about without i don't have an agenda
i don't have an agenda i mean you know
you're sort of doing that with me here
you just want
i mean you're you're letting me talk and
maybe i'm talking too much
not about your
you're like okay what are you about and
that's what i've always done and that's
the way
that's the way to build trust and i
always thought of my career
in the long term i never wanted to i
never
i was careful not to burn bridges i mean
i did little things back when
you know back when
stories were were read in the magazine
rather than online um i would always
send the magazine as soon as
as soon as i got it i would send the
magazine
to the subject you know let's say it was
ted turner
but i would send it to his assistant his
secretary his da
da da da with notes special not in one
pack but to them individually
i mean i did a lot of things like to pay
attention to the
people around the main person
because first of all
we need to respect them just as much as
the person who is
the subject and it it helped in the long
term i
i mean i knew i was sort of making a
little investment like oh this secretary
will
you know they were called secretaries
back then the secretary will
will like me yeah and look it makes a
ton of sense i think part of what is so
fascinating to me is you were ahead of
your time
in the style of interviewing that you
did now you were creating a written
piece of content most of the time but
but have since
evolved to kind of multimedia but
what i hear you talking about is um
the world of the media writer or kind of
content in general
because of the internet has brought
positives and negatives but one of the
negatives obviously is attention
span and so people have much shorter
attention spans and they want
you know quick hit pieces so you get
kind of articles written that way
you also get when people do television
interviews you get kind of three to five
minute
you know i need you to say something
salacious so we can get the headlines
and the distribution and like move on to
the next thing
and what's fascinating to me one just
because i
generally like to learn in the format
that i do the interviews
but there's also obviously very big
audiences for other people who are doing
kind of these long form interviews
is that it allows for the nuance
and it allows for the details and it
allows for kind of the explanations
behind
you know the headline type uh
perspective or opinion
and to me that's actually like 80 90
percent of the value
right it's one thing to know patty
sellers thinks x but to then hear you
kind of
explain for 10 minutes why do you think
of that
is do you fully believe that or do you
see the other side of the argument you
know
and kind of really dig into it to me
that's actually where all the value is
and it sounds like that's how you were
able to get
such intricate details and really kind
of tell a story about someone in a way
that others weren't able to is because
you just were able to let them talk and
you listen to the details right
yeah well back in the heyday when
fortune magazine was you know thick
i always felt that you know if you were
doing a big
story you could get ideally eight or ten
pages
and i always felt i had the opportunity
to do the definitive story about someone
and that was an honor
and uh i remember when i did the melinda
gates story i felt like i was
kind of holding something precious in in
my hands
because she was very nervous about it
and then the magazine
shrunk shrunk shrunk i mean as the
internet grew as
as digital media disintermediated print
media print media
died fortune magazine in his in its
physical form is still around but it's
it's very thin so this is like
you know five six years ago
doing a good job as a journalist at
fortune magazine became
writing stuff for the web
in the moment and how many eyeballs did
you get
on that story that was posted last night
and i was just like oh god this is not
fun i cannot i certainly cannot do
the definitive story if i have one day
uh or if i don't have a lot of space i
mean the internet's great you could
write as but but people don't have the
attention spans
and so anyway that led to
the idea for sellers east and media
which
is let us
use our skills our story to enter
interviewing and storytelling skills
and for people who can afford it
um we will tell your story
as long as you want as detailed as you
want
um on your timetable and
you can pick the audience if you want us
to build you a public website
we we we do that we build websites
we can help you reach millions but if
you want to give it to your kids
your three kids you can do that too we
ended up doing a
really fantastic documentary called port
of destiny
for um the president of colombia
is a man was a man named juan manuel
santos okay
he served eight terms until um
just two years ago and he won the nobel
peace prize for
settling with the farc rebels and ending
50
plus years of civil war in colombia an
amazing man
who talked about a roller coaster
rise to winning a nobel p
roller coaster path just a dramatic
story
blood guts murder you know um
bill clinton and tony blair who are huge
fans of his
were interviewed for it i interviewed
clinton
we did like a 50-minute 52-minute
documentary it was fantastic
but his people hired us this was like in
2017
i think like three years ago his people
hired us
because he was leaving office
he wanted a his story captured which had
never been captured for like his
post-presidential life
you know so he's like shown it at
venues around the world and events and
stuff and
but you know joe blow down the street
can't necessarily afford
to hire us to do that but you know
it's it's for a certain clientele and
our services actually our our services
actually come in as low as
we charge 38 000 for these filmed life
story interviews so
you know basically we we do stuff that's
but you know it's it's basically for
for companies and for people who have a
certain level of income
to capture their story in a way that
they can
control it and own it and
um and we tell it right we bring our
journalistic integrity and our
journalistic skills
and we pick our clients very carefully
yeah
one of the uh things that people will
always say is like hey i know a lot of
successful people
uh when it comes to you and nina
you guys literally probably have one of
the best rolodexes in terms of the
world's most successful
and powerful people to the point where
the washington post at one point wrote a
an article that said i think the
headline was something around uh the
rolodex that redefined power
right and was kind of referencing just
a lot of successful people and powerful
people want to
be around each other right they're kind
of it's a magnet
and and you've served as the the central
point for a lot of this for a long
period of time
um and uh paulina who has gone to uh the
uh most powerful women's conference uh
has told me that one of your favorite
questions to ask people is what does
power mean to you
so this is my chance to flip it on to
you and ask you after interviewing all
these people
you know spending literally months of
your life with them
what does power mean to you and kind of
how do you define the success that
a lot of these people have accomplished
in in their lifetimes
so power and this my definition of power
has evolved a bit
over the over the decades
power to me is
what you do beyond your job description
what you do beyond what you are
supposed to do beyond your designated
platform
and your tenure what you're paid to do
beyond what you're paid to do
and especially in this world that we're
living in right now
where everything can change tomorrow
and you may not have that job tomorrow
so if you can
look at yourself and if you
lose your job this afternoon
you can ask yourself okay i just lost my
job
am i still powerful if you can say yes
to that
then you're powerful i love that answer
my uh
my last question before we get into a
set of rapid fire questions to finish up
is you've told the story of the
successful and powerful people
and you uh today in the business that
you run
help to kind of cement the legacy of
many of these people by telling these
stories to uh
to kind of private audiences uh what is
the
legacy for patty sellers in kind of your
dream world
what do you kind of leave behind or
would love for people to say you know
what patty sellers
she did x
boy that is a really interesting
question anthony i
i actually have never been asked it and
um
when i when i interview people i tend to
ask
um you know you don't want to say what
do you want on your tombstone
but i i i tend to ask what do you want
on your billboard
okay and i i actually don't know what i
would say but i'm going to answer your
question
so i
i want i i feel
i care about making an impact and i care
about making a positive
impact and i believe
that the best way i can make an impact
on this world
on this world whether it's helping to
empower women which i feel like i've
done
a lot in that in that space
over the decades by building
being part of the team co-founding and
and building fortune most powerful women
which is now the biggest leadership
women's leadership community
on earth the most the premiere
or you know we're doing a film about
civil rights
leadership in the 21st century right now
at a time when
that topic is very timely and important
i'm a storyteller
and if i can help people who are good
people and people who live
lives of impact
if i can help them get their story out
there
and even pass it on to their next
generation
so that their kids and grandkids and by
watching
their father or grandfather tell his
their story
if if that can make the world a little
bit of a better place
then i feel like i've done a good job
and that's really all i
that's really all i care about i mean
i'm very happy in my life
i don't want to be wealthier i live on
the upper west side of manhattan
i have a good view out my window looking
out onto broadway i don't want
anything more i love
working with smart people i like one of
my rules of
sort of career rules has always been
work with people who are smarter than
you are
nina easton my co-ceo is smarter than
i am in many areas
i'd like to think she'd tell me that i'm
smarter than she is in a couple of areas
too but
i love that i'm learning every day i
want to keep learning
and i want to help keep i want to keep
helping
through this talent i have
um i want to help people who actually
can make an impact making a bigger
impact than they ordinarily would be
able to
you've done a fantastic job you've told
some of the uh the most incredible
stories and i think uh with such
intricate detail
that people you know kind of the results
speak for themselves
not only have you been able to get
people to agree to do that because they
trust you but but i think that uh
it's one of these things where you can
trick somebody one time
right but if you do a bad job or uh or
you end up
kind of violating that trust then you
don't get a second shot you don't get
any of their friends or anything like
that but uh
for decades you've been doing this
that's pretty cool uh i
finish up each conversation with the
same two questions and then you're going
to get to ask me one at the end to
finish it
the first is what is your favorite book
or what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh boy my favorite book of of
of all time of all time
um you know i just
i mean i'm going to mention a book that
i just finished i just finished last
week
it's called the warmth of other suns and
it's by isabel wilkerson who just
came out with this book cast c-a-s-t-e
that is uh
very high on the best-seller list
isabelle wilkerson is a pulitzer
prize-winning former new york times
journalist who
the warmth of other sons is about the
migration of
black people within the united states
from south to north
during the like 30s 40s and 50s and 60s
and it was just it's
it was it's a beautifully beautifully
written book and
um i mean i have certain favorites from
you know kind of my youth
like um the great gatsby and
um uh you know just sort of like
classics but
in terms of books that i've recently
read i would say that that is
important and timely and my favorite
i love that um my second question
is a little bit more fun which is aliens
are you a believer
or non-believer a non-believer
wait why
i wanna i want to add obviously you're a
believer which makes me want to say
wait why well it's just
so all right so i'll go first uh it's
just a math equation though
the galaxy and other galaxies are so big
the probability that we're the only
living beings and you know anywhere in
the
kind of unlimited expansiveness of uh of
the universe
is uh in my opinion quite small and so
if you're just playing the probability
game
then mathematically it would suggest
it's more likely than not
uh and then i think that there's this
like um kind of
uh seductive like intellectual curiosity
around uh everyone wants their to be the
aliens right and they want to believe
that we're not here alone
uh they want to um kind of pontificate
about are we going to meet them
or are they going to come and meet us
and you know how does that play out
and you know who knows what information
and who's hiding the information like
there's this whole
you know kind of uh society or culture
around it that i think
is uh fascinating to me personally uh
but i just fall back on the math so why
don't you yeah i mean
i i think that's reasonable to think
that way i mean the
everything that's happened this year i
mean everything like first and foremost
kovid has made me think more than ever
about our place in this universe um
like there's a lot of stuff this year
like my mother
would have just turned 100 years old and
i think of my grandparents who i knew
who were i realized like i never
realized this until just recently
that they were they lived
they lived you know like 30 years after
the civil war
and it's just so weird to think in this
vulnerable place that we are in right
now as
americans with kovitz still ranging
right raging and the the earth
at you know whether you look at climate
change or
or pandemic or whatever how vulnerable
we
are and i mean i guess
every generation thinks that they're
living through historic times
but what we experienced with one thing i
didn't mention was you know who the
first person who showed me the internet
was
no but i would love to know mark
andreessen
really yeah all right you gotta tell us
that story real quick
yeah really quick i was doing a story in
1995
called don't call me slacker
that was a that was a popular term then
and it was about america's most
successful
20-something so it was an idea i had
let's do this was before the internet so
there weren't many successful
20-somethings and i interviewed
a few people who are still known today
including jeff zucker who's now head of
cnn who was
executive producer of the today show at
the time 29 years old and
anyway i went out to california to a
company called mosaic
which was just changing its name
uh at the time but mark was this kid
who like 24 years old um
it was just changing its name to
netscape and
he he sat in the hallway in front of a
computer and he said i want to show you
how this works
and this browser this internet browser
that we have it was the first internet
browser that was
you know available to the public and he
said let me show you this
and he you know there was like a a line
there
and he said see that underlying word
like mexico if i click on that
click and it took you to like a page
about mexico
and i was like oh my god so anyway
i feel like we feel like
we have lived through amazing amazing
times
okay does every generation feel like
this okay
so now 2020 we are living through
amazing times
and i don't know it's the first time i'm
thinking it could all like go
poof tomorrow but i hope it doesn't
because i'm an optimist i think that
everyone questions everything in times
of uncertainty
i think is a very fair thing what uh
what one question do you have for me
to uh to finish this up what's on your
billboard anthony
i say this all the time he was happy and
he had fun that's it
right it's uh i'm pretty open i think
with people and i tell them
like uh a long time ago um
well long more than a decade ago now uh
i had the uh fortunate and unfortunate
situation of i went to
war right and uh sitting in iraq
and you kind of go through certain
experiences and you realize that the
kind of mortality that all of us have
and i think it's one of these
life experiences where um some
people take the fork in the road that
ends up with you know
the ptsd and the depression and kind of
all the things that we know
can happen when people are in those
environments uh and then other people
actually come out
in a completely different you know kind
of end of the road which is
they end up realizing like none of us
are getting out of here alive
right and so like you might as well go
enjoy it and have fun
and literally live kind of life to the
fullest right the
kind of more cliche way of saying it and
when that became like something that
really i internalized
i started to realize like i'm going to
do the things that i want to do today
i don't really care about kind of the
long-term you know aspects of
of it i'm not somebody who kind of
mastered plans okay here's my 15-year
plan as to how i'm going to you know
become the ceo of the corporation where
i started at the lower level and you
know the
middle manager and you know it's just
not my my thing
and it also means that when you're doing
something like
there's going to be a day i wake up and
i'm going to say this podcast is no
longer fun
and on the day that happens i will stop
that day
right and i'll literally just tweet out
and say it's over had a great run
see you guys right but just this element
of
having the ability to kind of walk away
from things that aren't fun anymore
um i think is really important and it
goes back to uh
really just having your identity tied to
your name right your actions not to a
corporation to a job to any of that
stuff
um and i think that uh you know you you
were uh
the rare case where you actually had a
corporation for a very long time and
then left
and when you left you've now built a uh
a new company with your partner and
obviously uh not only has that one gone
well but it seems like
uh you've been able to take all the
great aspects of the work that you've
previously done
and you know kind of wrap it into a new
bundle and now
give it that to a very specific uh
customer base
which you know i'm cheating again
because we we recently
uh we're hanging out and it's obvious
you're happy you're having fun
right you're enjoying this and so i
think that's kind of like the whole goal
of it
real power is personal power
that is a fantastic statement
and and i just you know i talked about
sellers easton and nina easton and how
fantastic a co-ceo she is but
i we have a team we have like seven or
eight people
and they're fantastic and i just
what i love about this phase of my life
and career
is that i you know pivot pivot pivot
that's what everybody is supposed to be
doing right now
and boy it is fun pivoting and learning
every day
and i am i'm frankly glad that i
decided to pivot five years ago rather
than
like oh my god 2020s is here what do i
do
i feel like we're we're we're
it's it's it's good too but to this
point of not
planning anthony it's it's so important
you can't plan today
and you know i i sort of became famous
for this term about
thinking think of your career as a
jungle gym
which is swing to opportunities keep
your peripheral vision
um do not think of your career as a
ladder
because the next rung on the ladder you
have no idea what that is
if that's going to be secure given the
way the world is unpredictable and
changing
keep your peripheral vision
it might be wise to jump on that
opportunity that is lateral
or even below what you are now because
it's all about expanding your experience
base
and adaptability flexibility
is more important than ever so
it's just i i i love what you said about
you know you're a fork in the road and
you made a choice
but what we are doing right now in our
careers mutually i think is we're
learning every day and we're stretching
ourselves
and we do have personal power
and we might wake up tomorrow and say
yep
i'm gonna do something else and that's
fantastic we have the power to do that
i love that uh before i let you go where
can people find you on the internet uh
or find out more if they want to see all
the great work you guys are doing
thank you thank you uh it's
sellerseaston.com
s-e-l-l-e-r-s
e-a-s-t-o-n.com
i'm at patty p-a-t-t-i-e
make sure you add the i.e patty at
sellerseaston.com
so uh yeah i'd love to hear from your
friends and fans
and uh this is this is really fun
anthony can we do this every day
i was gonna say you know that i would
talk to you all day long if
you would let me no listen patty thank
you so much for doing this
you uh i think that people really love
this episode just uh
not only all the learning from it but
also the the entertaining stories you've
uh
you lived a life that i think many
people uh look at and say hey that that
was a lot of fun so uh thank you so much
for doing this and we'll definitely do
it again in the future
thank you anthony it was fun